[Musik]
ja die vierte panzerbrigade sozusagen
die gepanzerte fonds des
österreichischen bundesheeres ist ein
wesentlicher teil unserer einsatzkräfte
und das ziel der übung handwerk ist es
die gefecht technik auf ebene zug und
compagnie zu erlernen zu intensivieren
und teilweise auch verloren gegangene
fähigkeiten wieder zu erlangen
die vierte benutzt diese verbands übung
handwerk 19
um die notwendige technik die wir für
den konventionellen kampf benötigen hier
weiter aufzutreten und so
perfektionieren
[Musik]
unser personal besteht aus kadersoldaten
grundwehrdienern milizsoldaten und
kaderpräsenzeinheiten soldaten und ich
denke dass alle diese unterschiedliche
personengruppen rasch zusammengefunden
haben und nun gemeinsam zum übungs
erfolg beitragen
ja ich bin beeindruckt dass ein viertel
der soldaten aus milizangehörige besteht
die also hier im vollen umfang ihre
leistungen erbringen nachholbedarf gibt
es im aktiv stand um die miliz stand
weil aufgrund der ressourcen lage in den
vergangenen jahren viele einsparungen
getätigt werden müssten die wir jetzt
wieder kompensieren